نعم عبد السلام يعني هي معلومات اوليه عن
ما يقال عنه في وسائل الاعلام الاسرائيليه
بانها عمليه ولكن حتى الان الشرطه
الاسرائيليه لم تعلن اذا ما كانت عمليه
على خلفيه قوميه ام انها حادثه لكن حتى
الان وفقا للمعلومات كانت هناك عده مواقع
اكثر من موقع على الاقل فيه حادثه دهش
ايضا حادثه طعن وبحسب الاسعاف الاسرائيلي
هناك عدد من الاصابات اكثر من 11 مصابا في
عمليه دهس
وطعن من بينهم اصابه توصف وفقا للاسعاف
الاسرائيلي بانها حرجه وثلاثه اخرون
اصابات خطيره بالاضافه الى عدد اخر من
الاصابات والذين ينقلون الى المستشفيات
القريبه في مدينه رعنانا وهي مدينه تقع
الى الشمال الشرقي من مدينه تل ابيب ا
هناك صور فقط نجوان ننوه لهذه الصوره ايضا
لما يبدو انه السياره المستخدمه في عمليه
الدهس وقد ارتطمت باحد الاعمده كما
يبدو في حادث لا نعلم بطبيعه الحال ما
الذي جرى لكن هذه يبدو انها الصوره التي
ينقلها ال الجانب الاسرائيلي في صور اوليه
ايضا للسياره التي استخدمت في عمليه الدهس
وتبدو يبدو رجال الاسعاف حول هذه السياره
اعود اليك نجوان اذا المعلومات الاوليه 19
اسرائيليا مصابا ب حادثتي دهس وطعن ما
نعلمه بان احد المصابين حالته حرجه وثلاثه
اصاباتهم
خطيره نعم هذا وفقا للاسعاف الاسرائيلي تم
نقل 19 مصابا الى
المستشفيات القريبه وال المحاذيه من بينهم
اصابه
سوسف جروح الشخص بالحرجه جدا وهناك ثلاثه
اخرون اصيبوا بجروح خطيره وفقا للاسعاف
الاسرائيلي وهناك بحسب المعلومات ان
السياره كانت قد نفذت عمليات دهس او مره
اخرى تكون هذه حادثه دهس في اكثر من البعض
يشير الى
ان الواقع بان هذه
السياره دعست اشخاص في اكثر من موقع قد
يشير من جهه الى انها بالفعل عمليه دهس
متعمده ولكن ايضا الترجيحات تقول بان هذا
قد يكون ناجم عن
خلل في السياره في المركبه التي كان يقلها
الشخص وعليه لم يسيطر على السياره
وكانت نجم عن ذلك هذا العدد من المصابين
في اكثر من موقع لكن حتى الان يتم التعامل
مع هذه العمليه بانها عمليه عمليه عمليه
مزدوجه لدهس وطعن بنفس الوقت وا الشرطه
الاسرائيليه تتحدث الان عن ان هذه العمليه
هي عمليه استثنائيه وتقوم بصحف ما جرى
وخلفيه ايه ما حدث بطبيعه الحال هناك حاله
تاهب كبيره جدا في المدن داخل الخط الاخضر
لا سما في هذه المناطق التي تعتبر مناطق
في مركز اسرائيل في وسط اسرائيل مدينه
رعنان هي واحده من المدن التي تقع الى
الشمال الشرقي لمدينه تلبين و بدايه هذه
الصور هذه التي نتابعها الان والسؤال هنا
انه لم يتم اغلاق المنطقه حتى هذه اللحظه
باي شريط معين لم يتم ابعاد
الماره لانه نحاول ان نقرا المشهد لمحاوله
فهم ما الذي حدث لكن ما يبدو في هذه
الصوره هو ان عدد
من المواطنين العاديين يقفون هناك سيارات
اسعاف كثيره لكن لا يوجد تواجد امني كما
كنا نتابع في عمليات سابقه في تل ابيب
تحديدا يبدو ان هناك لا لا يوجد ابعاد
للمواطنين كل هذه ربما تعطي اشارات عن حجم
العمليه وطبيعتها لكن ما زلنا في انتظار
مزيد من التفاصيل
مج يعني هذه الصور هي في بدايه الحادثه
عبد السلام لذلك في البدايه بطبيعه الحال
يتم استدعاء سيارات الاسعاف لانقاذ وتقديم
العلاج للمصابين لكن باللحظه التي تتاكد
فيها الشرطه الاسرائيليه من معطيات تشير
الى ان ها عمليه على خلفيه قوميه وهنا
يبدا تبدا التحقيقات اولا بهويه الشخص
الذي كان يقود المركبه عندما يتم التاكد
على سبيل المثال بانه عربي او فلسطيني
سواء كان من الداخل الفلسطيني او من مناطق
الضفه الغربيه وتمكن من الوصول الى هذه
المدينه ف بالعاده يتم الاعلان فورا بانها
عمليه على خلفيه قوميه ويتم اغلاق المنطقه
لكن قد يتضح لاحقا السائق هو اسرائيلي
لذلك يتم التروي في بعض الاحيان حتى تعلن
الشرطه الاسرائيليه عن خلفيه هذه العمليه
وفي كثير من الاحيان حتى عندما يتم الحديث
عن ان السائق هو من فلسطيني الداخل او من
جهات اخرى ليس اسرائيليا ايضا يتم الاعلان
بانها عمليه دون اجراء اي تحقيق بمعنى انه
يتم اتهام الفلسطيني فورا اذا كان يقود
سياره سواء كانت الحاله هي حاله حاله طرق
او خلل في السياره